sur cette question ivan rioufol laurent
wauquiez il doit respecter la loi
tout le monde doit respecter la loi mais
est ce que la loi est bien interpréter
ou pas dans les faits moi je suis de
ceux qui pensent que naturellement la
laïcité et quel état est un marqueur qui
doit être respecté mais est ce que la
laïcité à ses intérêts c'est en effet à
une marque culturelle parce qu'on peut
considérer bien sûr que la crèche
aujourd'hui est devenu une marque
culturelle et dans le fond de
raisonnement dans le calme elle se tient
il a pu on n'y a pas ce n'est pas un
petit un petit enfant dans ce nom c'est
l'ange qui va mettre en péril la laïcité
française ils voient bien qu'il ya là
une incohérence et de faire ce
relativisme que j'entends maintenant de
dire oui mais si vous aussi vous si vous
autorisez les crèches il faut autoriser
le voile il faut autoriser les prières
dans la rue etc
on voit bien que le raisonnement il faut
ce dès le départ car dans l'autre côté
vous avez en fait effectivement des
prières dans la rue pour reprendre cet
exemple là qui sont vraiment des
affirmations politique religieuse d'une
identité et d'une visibilité dans
l'espace public et de l'autre côté vous
avez l'affirmation d'une tradition qui
se réveille en effet il ya pas se cacher
derrière son petit doigt il ya là
derrière ces initiatives
une manière de vouloir rappeler qu'ils
nous sommes mais je pense que cette
manière de vouloir rappeler notre
identité n'est pas fondamentalement
hostile à la laïcité d'autant que les
racines chrétiennes ont fourni le socle
de la laïcité
mon royaume n'est pas de ce monde et
donc moi je le suis de ce depuis
toujours qui pense qu'il aurait été
préférable en 2004 d'inscrire les
racines chrétiennes de l'europe dans la
constitution européenne
cette constitution qui a d'ailleurs été
refusée par une partie des français on
peut s'imaginer que peut-être que cette
lacune on était une des raisons